We should have a device with the raw capabilities of a human brain in our pocket sometime between 20 to 40 years from now. Okay. And if you think about the ramifications of that for society, that's huge. But there is huge risk, and I think we are underestimating the risk, right? Right. When people talk about kind of, you know, oh, the existential threat of AI and think Terminator, I don't think it's Terminator. I think it's a massive wealth disparity and, you know, leading to war, right? Right. I think that's the existential threat. A civil war? Or, you know, overthrow the government type of, you know. Welcome to ADSP the podcast, episode 250, recorded on August 21st, 2025. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we interview Sean Parent and get his thoughts on AI, its impact on our industry, society, and more.
我们应该会在未来20到40年内的某个时间点，在口袋里装上一台拥有人类大脑原始能力的设备。好吧。如果你思考一下这对社会的影响，那将是巨大的。但其中存在巨大的风险，我认为我们低估了这种风险，对吧？没错。当人们谈论人工智能的生存威胁并想到《终结者》时，我不认为那是《终结者》。我认为那是巨大的贫富差距，你知道，这会导致战争，对吧？没错。我认为那才是生存威胁。一场内战？或者，你知道，推翻政府之类的。欢迎收听ADSP播客，第250期，录制于2025年8月21日。我是Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人Bryce一起采访Sean Parent，了解他对人工智能及其对我们行业、社会等方面的影响的看法。
So here's a question that it's been in the back of my head ever since you said that. that, you know, will your book, you know, maybe it's the last book that'll ever be read. What is your, like, you've had a very long, you know, experienced career? Like, what is your take on where the art industry is going? Because, you know, there's lots of folks that are like us. They're treating this stuff like rocket fuel. It's an amplifier of your productivity. Other folks are super against it.
所以这里有一个问题，自从你说了那句话后，它就一直在我脑海里盘旋。就是，你知道，你的书，也许它是最后一本会被阅读的书。你有什么看法，毕竟你有着非常漫长且丰富的职业生涯？你对艺术行业的发展方向有什么看法？因为，你知道，有很多像我们这样的人。他们把这些东西当作火箭燃料。它是你生产力的放大器。而其他人则非常反对它。
And then, yeah, you made the comment as like, you know, are books going to be needed? Anyway, so I wonder if you have, like, larger thoughts on where the industry is headed and how people, I guess, maybe not how they should be feeling about it, just your thoughts and then people can feel how they want. Yeah, so I don't think it's an industry issue so much as a societal issue. And if I kind of do the back of the envelope calculations, we should have a device with the raw capabilities of a human brain in our pocket, sometime between 20 to, 40 years from now, okay? And if you think about the ramifications of that for society, that's huge. That changes everything and in a relatively short time frame.
然后，是的，你发表了评论，比如，你知道，书还需要吗？总之，我想知道你是否对行业的发展方向以及人们——我猜，也许不是他们应该对此有何感受，只是你的想法，然后人们可以有他们想要的感受。是的，我不认为这是一个行业问题，而更多是一个社会问题。如果我做一下粗略的计算，我们应该会在未来20到40年内的某个时间点，在口袋里装上一台拥有人类大脑原始能力的设备，好吗？如果你思考一下这对社会的影响，那将是巨大的。这在相对较短的时间内改变了一切。
And so there's all this like, like, you know, we're burning up the planet building data centers and building power plans to power these data centers. Well, by the time most of those come online, if you plot the curves, they won't be necessary. Great. When we think about a human brain, the advantages that a human brain has over our current silicon is it's a three-dimensional structure, which provides some amount of density. It's analog-based, which means you get more bang per neuron than you do if you're running your transistors as digital transistors. And the whole thing runs on about 20 watts. And we are not yet at the point where we're simulating the full number of neurons in a single human brain. even with our large LLM models. But we will get there relatively rapidly.
所以现在有所有这些，你知道，我们为了建造数据中心和发电厂来为这些数据中心供电，正在烧毁地球。好吧，等到其中大多数投入使用时，如果你绘制曲线，它们将不再必要。太棒了。当我们思考人类大脑时，人类大脑相对于我们目前的硅基芯片的优势在于它是一个三维结构，这提供了一定的密度。它是基于模拟的，这意味着你从神经元中获得的收益比你将晶体管作为数字晶体管运行时要多。而且整个东西运行在约20瓦的功率上。我们还没有达到模拟单个人类大脑中全部神经元数量的地步，即使使用我们的大型LLM模型也是如此。但我们将相对迅速地达到这一目标。
And then lots of people are working on, like, how do we build chips that are more 3D, right? How do we expand out? How do we build the cooling infrastructure to them? How do we combine the RAM with the computation within the chip instead of having it on separate buses? How do we do analog chips? All of these problems are being worked on,
然后很多人正在研究，比如，我们如何制造更立体的芯片，对吧？我们如何向外扩展？我们如何为它们建立冷却基础设施？我们如何将RAM与芯片内的计算结合起来，而不是让它在单独的总线上？我们如何制造模拟芯片？所有这些问题都在研究中，
and all of them are going to fall. So the advantages of the human brain are going to eventually lose out. What I don't think we know yet is how does intelligence scale? I think with even open AI, what you're seeing is a tapering. You're having to build significantly larger models to get marginal winds. And I suspect that intelligence scales by some quadratic function, right? which may mean that there's you know people talk about a super ai i think we'll eventually build ais that are smarter than us but i don't know how much smarter right there's going to be a
而且它们都会被攻克。因此，人类大脑的优势最终将会丧失。我认为我们还不知道的是智能是如何扩展的。我认为即使是OpenAI，你所看到的也是一种递减。你必须构建明显更大的模型才能获得边际收益。我怀疑智能是以某种二次函数扩展的，对吧？这可能意味着，你知道，人们谈论超级人工智能，我认为我们最终会构建出比我们更聪明的人工智能，但我不知道会聪明多少，对吧？将会有一个
a law of diminishing returns on how that intelligence scales i also think there's a very fine line between you know intelligence and madness right right intelligence is being able to see patterns in data and being able to apply patterns you see from one set of data to another set of data. And, you know, madness has seen patterns that aren't there, right? Right? And there's a really fine line. And if you know super smart people, you see that line, right? So that might also be a limiting factor, right? We might build AI that start to see, you know, the pattern in pie, you know, and just reach a, reach a point where they're not useful because they construct patterns that don't actually exist to fit data, you know. So, so there's a lot of
智能扩展的收益递减规律。我还认为在智能和疯狂之间有一条非常细的界限，对吧？没错。智能是能够看到数据中的模式，并能够将你从一组数据中看到的模式应用到另一组数据中。而且，你知道，疯狂是看到了不存在的模式，对吧？对吧？这确实有一条非常细的界限。如果你认识超级聪明的人，你会看到那条线，对吧？所以这也可能是一个限制因素，对吧？我们可能会构建出开始看到，你知道，圆周率中的模式的人工智能，你知道，然后达到一个点，它们变得不再有用，因为它们构建了并不实际存在的模式来拟合数据，你知道。所以，所以有很多
unknowns. But I think everybody keeps focusing on like what happens to the computer science industry. Yeah, I was, I was just going to ask, John, this is a, I think, the toughest environment that I've seen for hiring in the CS industry in my time. And I'm just inundated by people asking for advice, looking for jobs. And I wonder whether you, as a far more experience than Connor and I, can maybe pontificate on what you think this means for the industry. And also, what should, what should like a new college grad do or somebody who's in school and thinking about a CS degree. But also, too, I think Sean was just about to say is that, like, there's a larger problem
未知数。但我认为每个人都在关注计算机科学行业会发生什么。是的，我正要问，John，我认为这是我从业以来见过的计算机科学行业招聘环境最艰难的一次。我被那些寻求建议、寻找工作的人淹没了。我想知道你作为比Connor和我经验丰富得多的人，是否可以高谈阔论一下你认为这对行业意味着什么。还有，刚毕业的大学生或还在学校考虑计算机科学学位的人应该做什么。但我也认为，Sean刚才要说的是，有一个更大的问题
that is a larger scope than CS. So feel free to answer both, but I'm curious to hear where you were headed before Bryce injected the CS. I think on this front, you know, we're the tip of the sphere. And the only reason why we're the tip of the sphere is because we're the ones building the systems. And so the problems we're solving first are the problems we have. But like I said, I think this is a societal issue, not a computer science issue, and it's going to become a larger societal issue rapidly, you know, and I don't know how society adjusts for that.
其范围比计算机科学更大。所以请随意回答这两个问题，但我很好奇在Bryce插入计算机科学之前你想表达什么。我认为在这方面，你知道，我们是矛尖。我们之所以是矛尖，唯一的原因是我们是构建系统的人。所以我们首先解决的问题是我们自己的问题。但正如我所说，我认为这是一个社会问题，而不是计算机科学问题，而且它很快就会变成一个更大的社会问题，你知道，我不知道社会如何适应这一点。
20 to 40 years put the kind of the late stages of my life, assuming I may get that far out. So this is more of a problem for you guys than it is for me. You know, that said, take it all with a bit of a grain of salt. When I switched my major in school from double E to computer science, my dad gave me this very long lecture about what a bad move that was because by the time I graduated college, computers would be programming themselves and I'd be out of a job. And that was just all around, you know, expert systems were the rage at the time. And you can look up what an expert system is, but it's basically just a decision tree and not particularly interesting these days. But that was the thinking at the time. But I do think that this is very much different, and the pace of change is incredibly rapid here.
20到40年处于我生命的后期，假设我能活到那么久。所以这对你们来说比对我来说更是个问题。你知道，话虽如此，对此持保留态度。当我在学校把专业从电子工程转到计算机科学时，我父亲给了我一个非常长的讲座，说这是一个多么糟糕的举动，因为等我大学毕业时，计算机将能够自我编程，而我将失业。那是在专家系统风靡一时的时期。你可以查一下什么是专家系统，但它基本上只是一个决策树，在今天看来并不是特别有趣。但那是当时的思维方式。但我确实认为这非常不同，而且这里的变化速度非常快。
And, you know, for a new computer science student, you know, what I would be saying is learn to use the tools, including AI. and use AI to learn and learn the fundamentals and learn when the AI is wrong. That will be probably the best bet you have to extend your career. But that would be kind of general advice to any college student, right? If you're coming out saying, I'm going to be a lawyer or an accountant or whatever, right? The legal industry is very much getting hit by the AI wave. So are medical doctors. So are everybody, right?
而且，你知道，对于一名新的计算机科学专业的学生，你知道，我会说的是学会使用工具，包括人工智能。并利用人工智能来学习，学习基础知识，并了解人工智能何时出错。这可能是你延长职业生涯的最佳选择。但这对于任何大学生来说都是一般的建议，对吧？如果你出来说，我要成为一名律师或会计师什么的，对吧？法律行业正受到人工智能浪潮的巨大冲击。医生也是如此。每个人都是，对吧？
If you're a medical doctor, you have an incredible diagnostic tool sitting right next to you, you know, with a huge amount of knowledge and more than you could ever hold in your head. Plus, you know, with things like deep research, the ability to go do significant research on a given problem and come back with something well structured and well thought through. So I think focusing on AI or focusing on computer science is way too narrow. Like I get asked frequently, you know, do we hire more senior people so that they can use the AIs and be more productive or do we hire more junior people who are willing to learn the AIs and so they can grow into senior people who know how to use the AIs?
如果你是一名医生，你的身边就有一个令人难以置信的诊断工具，你知道，它拥有巨大的知识量，超过了你大脑所能容纳的任何东西。加上，你知道，像深度研究这样的东西，有能力对给定的问题进行深入研究，并带回结构良好、深思熟虑的内容。所以我认为专注于人工智能或专注于计算机科学太狭隘了。就像我经常被问到，你知道，我们是应该雇佣更多资深人员，以便他们可以使用人工智能并提高生产力，还是雇佣更多愿意学习人工智能的初级人员，这样他们就可以成长为知道如何使用人工智能的资深人员？
I'm like, it is way too soon to tell this, you know, the generation, rate that that's going on with the models right now is every six months the equation changes. That's nuts, right? So, and I think it will, I don't think it's, you know, a lot of people are like, everybody makes this mistake as people, you know, when you're at the start of a curve, you project things linearly, and you miss the fact that it's going to exponentially wrap up. And then when it's exponentially ramping up, you overshoot. almost everything works out to be an s curve right right exponential growth is not sustainable
我说，现在下结论还为时过早，你知道，模型现在的生成速度是每六个月方程就会改变。这太疯狂了，对吧？所以，我认为它会，我不认为它是，你知道，很多人就像，每个人都会犯这个错误，人们，你知道，当你处于曲线的起点时，你线性地预测事物，而忽略了它将呈指数级上升的事实。然后当它呈指数级上升时，你就会过度预测。几乎所有事情最终都会变成S曲线，对吧？没错，指数增长是不可持续的
right right almost nothing follows a linear path right right it's it's 10% better than it was the previous time not not a unit of 10 better than the previous time and so so you know and it will follow an exponential taper off at the top of that s curve and it's very hard to predict where you are in that curve right right now i think we are i don't think we are yet near the top we are some place my guess is bottom middle and so so the next five to ten years are going to be nuts and then it's going to taper off and and there's going to be a lot of bad decisions made along the way people are going to both underestimate the capabilities and then they're going to overestimate the capabilities and make decisions based off bad projections.
对吧，几乎没有什么遵循线性路径，对吧？它比上一次好10%，而不是比上一次好10个单位。所以，你知道，它会遵循指数级并在S曲线的顶部趋于平缓，而且很难预测你处于曲线的哪个位置，对吧？现在我认为我们，我不认为我们接近顶部，我们处于某个地方，我的猜测是底部中间。所以接下来的五到十年将会非常疯狂，然后它会趋于平缓，并且在此过程中会做出很多错误的决定。人们既会低估能力，然后又会高估能力，并基于错误的预测做出决定。
Do you have, I'm curious, I mean, this is, clearly you've spent, I mean, a lot of time thinking about this. Do you have, like, concrete examples or predictions of the kind of both mistakes and on the other side, like, not mistakes, but just like, you know, inevitabilities that are going to happen along this curve? So, like, like everything kind of in the, in the, in the political. structure, right, the mistakes that are frequently made in a war are fighting the last battle. And in political structures, the mistakes that are made are fighting the mistakes of the last
你有没有，我很好奇，我的意思是，这显然你花了很多时间思考这个问题。你有没有，比如，具体的例子或预测，关于这种曲线过程中会发生的错误，以及另一方面，不是错误，而只是，你知道，必然会发生的事情？所以，就像，像政治结构中的一切，对吧，战争中经常犯的错误是打上一场战争。而在政治结构中，犯的错误是与上一届政府或上一轮的错误作斗争，而不是向前看并为未来做计划。所以我们如何从政治角度出发，你知道，就业增长和富人的利润以及涓滴效应，特别是如果你这些天在美国的话，对吧？你知道，我认为对于我赚多少钱来说，我的税率低得离谱。然而，我们的政府认为我的口袋里需要更多的钱，而我街对面的人需要更少。这太荒谬了。他们试图做的是说，好吧，我们要削减基础设施网络，并试图为这些人提供工作理由，而你即将进入一个阶段，在某些行业它已经开始发生，即工作，即使是高层工作，
administration or the last round and not looking forward and planning for the future. So how we're approaching from kind of a political standpoint, you know, job growth and And profits for the wealthy and trickle-down effects, especially if you're in the U.S. these days, right? You know, my taxes are, I think, ridiculously low for how much money I make. And yet, our administration thinks that I need more money in my pocket and the people down the street from me need less. And that's ridiculous. And what they're trying to do is say, well, we're going to cut out infrastructure nets and try to provide reasons for these people to work where you're about to hit, a phase, and in some industries it's already hitting, where jobs, even high-level jobs,
也将开始相对迅速地消失。所以我认为不为此做计划，不从社会本质上走在前面，是目前正在发生的低估。你知道，如果你的劳动力中有20%是无法就业的，会发生什么，好吧，他们会把这个地方烧掉。对吧。想象一下占领华尔街，但更糟。更糟。
are going to start to go away relatively fast. And so I think that's not planning for that and not getting out front of that from a societal nature is the underestimation that's going on right now. You know, what happens if you have 20% of your workforce, which is unemployable, okay, they'll burn the place down. Right. Picture Occupy Wall Street, but way worse. Way worse.
是的。那么你如何应对这种情况，你如何避免这种情况？你知道，我并不是说这一定会发生，因为人们是非常反动的，对吧？对吧。当问题开始显现时，他们会调整，但社会本质上是等到问题变得严重时才去解决它。然后你可能会矫枉过正。所以我认为我们会遇到这种情况。我认为我们需要认真思考。
Yeah. So how do you navigate that and how do you avoid that? You know, I'm not saying that that's going to happen because people are very reactionary, right? Right. They will, they'll adjust as the problem starts to manifest, but it's kind of societal nature is to wait until the problem is critical before you address it. and then you probably overcorrect. So I think we're going to run into that. I think we need to give some serious thought.
我们想要的社会是拥有人工智能的半打组织，而基本上其他人都在从属于他们吗？这有点像，我正在Hulu上看的《三体》。这有点像其中的背景前提，即基本上有少数几家人工智能公司，六七家，运行着整个星球。基本上，政府已经消失了。只是企业在负责。
Is the society that we want where there is a half dozen organizations that own the AI and basically everybody else is subservient to them? That's kind of the, I'm watching on Hulu, the alien earth. And that's kind of part of the background premise on that, which is that there's basically a small number of AI companies, six or seven, that run the entire planet. Basically, governments are gone. It's just just businesses in charge.
或者它让我想起尼尔·斯蒂芬森的一些书，比如《雪崩》。是的，是的，是的。它是，你知道，或者即使你只是看，你知道，你上个世纪有强盗大亨，谁控制了交通基础设施谁就统治。所以如果你建造了铁路，你就负责。我认为我们正在达到历史上的一个类似点，但被极大地放大了。而且我不认为我们的政治结构是为了试图解决这个问题而建立的，至少现在不是。在许多方面，情况正在变得更糟。
Or it reminds me of some of Neil Stevenson's books like Snow Crash. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's, you know, or even if you just look, you know, you had kind of last century, you had robber barons and you had whoever controlled the transportation infrastructure ruled. So if you built the railroads, you were in charge. I think we're hitting a similar point in history, but greatly amplified. And I don't think our political structure is set up to try to address this, at least not now. In many ways, it's getting worse.
这就是为什么所有的科技人员都非常支持全民基本收入，对吧？是的，是的。从历史上看，我会称自己为保守派。现在，你知道，我是一名注册民主党人，但我仍然认为自己有点，你知道，乔治·布什，第一个本质上的保守派。你知道，我认为共和党现在是有毒的。但我认为工作有巨大的价值。
This is why all the tech people are, you know, big on the universal basic income, right? Yeah, yeah. Historically, I would have called myself conservative. Now, you know, I'm a registered Democrat, but I still consider myself kind of, you know, George Bush, the first conservative in nature. You know, I think the Republican Party is toxic as it stands now. But I think there is huge value in work.
我不认为人们在一个他们不需要工作的社会中运作良好，至少绝大多数人是这样。工作有社会层面。有一种成就感。通过工作，你的生活有一种意义感和目的感。所以我认为答案不是，嘿，我们只是保证你们都有房子、食物和居住的地方。我认为应该有一个有保障的基本基质。但我不认为那是答案。你最终会因为那些只是，你知道，手头有太多时间的人而产生大量的社会问题，对吧？我认为疫情向我们展示了那种孤立对社会心理健康造成的损害
I don't think people function well in a society where they don't have. to work at least the vast majority of people. There are social aspects to work. There's a sense of accomplishment. There's a sense of meaning and purpose that comes to your life through work. And so I don't think the answer is, is, hey, we'll just guarantee that you all have a home and food and a place to live. I think there should be a basic substrate that is guaranteed. But I don't think that's the answer. You will end up a huge number of societal problems from people who just, you know, have too much time on their hand, right? I think the pandemic kind of showed showed us the damage that that kind of isolation does
所以我认为我们需要弄清楚我们如何让人们富有成效，对吧？对吧。我们如何提供机会？我们如何提供有意义的工作？我们如何在一个机器可以做得更好的世界里提供成就感。嗯。
to mental health for society. So I think we need to figure out how do we make people productive, right? Right. How do we provide opportunities? How do we provide meaningful work? How do we provide a sense of accomplishment in a world where the machine can do it better. Uh-huh.
你知道，我认为这真的很难，对吧？哦，天哪，这是播客的黄金内容，Sean。我的意思是，这甚至不是播客的黄金。这简直是纯金。我的意思是，太多的想法了。这让我想起了一个我13、14年前，在2011年，在我第一次合作时一起工作过的人，当我
You know, and I think that's really hard, right? Oh, man, this is podcast gold, Sean. I mean, it's not even podcast gold. This is just pure gold. I mean, so many thoughts. And it makes me think about there was a guy I used to work with 13, 14 years ago in 2011, in my first. co-op when I
来到多伦多，为一家保险公司工作，这个叫Paul的人，Paul很棒，我喜欢Paul，我没有直接和他一起工作，或者也许我工作过
came to Toronto worked for an insurance company this guy named Paul Paul was great I loved Paul I didn't work directly with him or maybe I did
他在我的团队里，但我从没和他一起工作过，但他参加过几次活动，我记得他有一次告诉我，因为你知道，精算师的薪水很高，他说，好吧，如果你是一名精算师
he was on my team but I never worked with him but he was at a couple functions and I remember him telling me once that because you know actuaries they get paid quite well and he's like well if you're an actuary
你必须，你必须倾向于左派，我说，好吧，你不必，你可以选择任何你想要的，他说，不，不，不，你必须像一个自由派民主党人，无论你在哪里，我说
you have to be you have to be you have to lean left I was like well you don't have to you can choose whatever you want and he's like no no no you have to be like a whatever is liberal Democrat wherever you are and I was like
像，好吧，你的理由是什么？他说，好吧，在某个时候，你知道，我们将达到这一点，我们将进化，你知道，用，我不确定他是否在谈论人工智能，但他只是认为会有，你知道，某种人们在工作，而人们不在工作。在那个社会里，就像，你想要福利制度和全民基本收入，你需要一种方式来支持社会中的每个人。因为否则，精算师将不得不去拿一把猎枪，去接管他们当地的No Frills，那是一家杂货店。我们将不得不像自生自灭一样，因为社会将翻转
like, okay, what's your reasoning for that? And he's like, well, at some point, you know, we're going to get to this point where we're going to evolve, you know, with, I don't sure he was talking about AI, but he just thinks there's going to be, you know, kind of people that are working and people that aren't working. And in that society, like, you want welfare systems and universal basic income and you need a way to support everyone in society. Because otherwise, the actuaries are going to have to go and get a shotgun, go take over their local no frills, which is like a grocery store. And we're going to have to like fend for ourselves because like society is going to flip
棋盘，你知道，寓意上。因为，是的，如果你不这样做，它就不会成功。就像我们需要关心社会中的所有人类。你不能只是这种我少交税所以我可以更富有。这根本行不通。总之。这基本上就是你触及的。我甚至没想到现在，不幸的是，美国正在撤销大量的
the board game table, you know, proverbially. Because, yeah, it's not going to work out if you don't. Like we need to care about all humans in society. You can't just this whole I pay less taxes so I can be more rich. It just doesn't work. Anyways. And that's basically what you were touched. And I never even thought of the fact that right now, unfortunately, America is undoing a ton
这些安全网和计划。显然这很糟糕，但我甚至没有在失业率可能在未来，我不知道，五年、十年，无论多久内飙升的背景下考虑它，但是，我的意思是，如果你去，只有科技裁员会追踪它，
of these safety nets and programs. and obviously that sucks, but I didn't even think about it in the context of, you know, unemployment could be skyrocketing in the next, I don't know, if it's five years, ten years, however long, but, I mean, if you go to, it's only the tech layoffs that it tracks,
但有一个网站叫trueup.io/layoffs。我可以把它放在聊天里，你们俩都可以点击它，但看起来不太好。它基本上是，如果你取平均值，它要么是一条向上的线性线，要么是一条正在增长的抛物线。它有点偏颇，因为英特尔在7月份裁掉了21,000人。
but there's a website called trueup.io slash layoffs. I can put it in the chat, and you guys can both click on it, but it doesn't look great. It's basically, if you take the average, it's either a linear line going up or a parabolic curve that's growing. It is kind of biased because Intel laid off 21,000 people in July.
他们按月追踪它，微软也一直在进行大量的裁员。他们对软件已死评价很高。我不记得是CEO还是CTO说了什么。但总之，是的，很多想法。我真的，我没有解决方案。我不确定。你，听起来你读了很多历史，因为你在引用，我对乔治·布什一世了解不多。
They track it by month, and Microsoft has been doing a bunch of layoffs. And they're pretty high on the software's dead. I can't remember if it was the CEO or CTO that said something. But anyways, yeah, a lot of thoughts. I don't really, I have no solution. I'm not sure. Are you, it sounds like you read quite a bit of history because you're quoting the, I don't know much about George Bush number one.
微软的残酷。微软这里很残酷。是的，如果你们想去看看，我会把链接放在节目说明里。我想如果你按年份看裁员，我想……你能按公司查吗？你知道，我在乔治·布什一世时期实际上是一个有投票权的成年人。哦。所以你不必成为历史学者。
Bruttle at Microsoft. Brutal at Microsoft here. Yeah, I'll put a link in the show notes, folks, if you want to go check. And I guess if you go layoffs by year, I guess... Can you look at it up by company? You know, I was actually a voting adult during, you know, George Bush is the first. Oh. So you don't need to be a scholar in history.
我经历了很多历史。你只需要活着并关注它。我想我出生时，我想，是在他任期的中间。所以我想那是老布什，对吧？是的。是的。他是88年到92年。是的。
I've lived a lot of history. You just have to have been alive for it and paying attention. And I guess I was born, I think, like in the middle of his term. So I think that's the H-Bush, right? Yes. Yeah. He was 88 to 92. Yeah.
所以我伊拉克战争期间在苹果工作。所以，是的，我想Bryce和我都是那时出生的。所以我们没有。是的。是的，我想我们应该试着以某种方式结束，比如，有希望吗？我的意思是，我们甚至没有谈论我们甚至没有谈论机器人
So I was working at Apple during the Iraq War. So I, yeah, I think Bryce and I were both born then. So we weren't. Yes. Yeah, I guess should we try and end on like, is there hope? I mean we didn't even talk about we didn't even talk about the robots
你知道，最终会有机器人，所有这些东西都会插在上面，你知道，是的，你会把其中一个机器人放在你的家里吗，呃，当然
you know eventually there's going to be robots that all these things are going to be plugged into you know yeah would you have one of the robots in your in your home uh sure
是的，我很乐意，我的意思是，就像我总是，你知道，我们被《杰森一家》承诺过，我们将拥有飞行汽车和
yeah I would love you I mean it's like I'm always like you know we were promised by the you know from the Jetsons that we were going to have flying cars and
你知道，会打扫我们房子的女佣Rosie，这样我们就有更多的时间进行创造性工作，而我们得到的是，呃，呃，呃，你知道，图像生成和歌曲生成，所以我们自动化了创造性工作，这样我们就有更多的时间去洗衣服和打扫房子，嗯，你听说过Loom吗，Loom，是的，我们知道什么是Loom，它是拼写为L-U-M-E
and you know Rosie the maid who would vacuum our house so we would have more time for our creative endeavors and instead what we've got is uh uh uh you know image generation and song generation and so so we've automated the creative endeavors so we have more time to fold the laundry and vacuum the house um have you have you heard about the loom the loom yeah we know what a loom is It's spelled L-U-M-E
你得去网站看，他们可以播放一小段视频，然后你得告诉我，你得告诉我你的想法，你们俩，好吧，你们可能得剪掉导航到Loom的部分，不，我已经在看了
You got to go to the website And watch They can play a little video for a second And then you've got to tell me You gotta tell me your thoughts, both of you Okay You might have to cut out the navigate to the loom here No, I'm already watching
这只是，等着瞧吧，是的，也许不是，也许不是连接到床上，我，我已经见过那种版本的机器人，它们是有轮子的，四处走动，捡起东西并把它们放好
This is Just wait for it Yeah, maybe not Maybe not attached to the bed I'm like, I've already seen the robots that are like a version of this that are on wheels that go around and pick things up and put them in a way
我们肯定会得到那个，因为我不想说我心爱的人的坏话，但她在组织方面比我稍微差一点……我会谈谈Ramona。到处都是衣服。她真的不会做
and we're definitely getting that because I don't want to talk poorly of my beloved but she is a little less organized than me in terms of... I'll talk about I'll talk about Ramona. There are clothes everywhere. She literally will not do
洗衣。她不会洗衣服。我是家里唯一洗衣服的人。但是好吧，那么为听众描述一下，砰，视频开始时，你面前有一张床，旁边有一些家具，床旁边有两盏灯，高高的灯。有人过来把一些衣服留在床上，然后他们走开了。然后突然灯活了过来，小爪子从灯的末端伸出来。然后灯弯下腰
the laundry. She will not do the laundry. I'm the only person does laundry in the house. But okay, so describe for the listener, boom, the video starts off where there's this bed in front of you, there's some furniture next to it, and there's these two lamps, tall lamps next to the bed. And somebody comes and leaves some clothes on the bed and they walk away. And then suddenly the lamps come alive and little claw hands stick out of the end of the lamps. And then the lamps sort of bend over
它们开始折叠衣服。当我第一次看到这个时，我真的以为这是一个笑话。因为，我的意思是，这是一个有趣的形状因素。它看起来确实像是一个笑话，对吧？是的。但我想要它。你需要一个不同版本的，因为你不希望它只是折叠它并把它放在床尾。
and they start folding up the clothes. And when I first saw this, I really thought it was a joke. because it, I mean, it's an interesting form factor. It's just, it does seem like it's a joke, right? Yeah. I want it, though. You need a different version of this, though, because you don't want it just to fold it and put it on the end of the bed.
你希望它去，比如，整理你的衣柜，把所有东西挂起来并折叠在那里，对吧？就像连接到床上根本没有意义。在乐观的一面，你知道，我认为这里正在发生令人难以置信的事情，对吧？我认为，你知道，在人工智能的各个方面，对吧？我使用生成式人工智能做很多事情，编码，你知道，编辑照片，当然是在Adobe。写作，它帮助我。我很乐意让它驾驶我的车。我还没有自动驾驶汽车，但我会得到的。你知道，我也
You want it to go, like, organize your closet and hang everything and fold it there, right? Like, attached to the bed makes no sense. On the upbeat, you know, I think there's incredible stuff going on here, right? I think, you know, in every aspect of the AI, right? I use generative AI for a bunch of stuff, coding, you know, editing photos, being at Adobe, of course. Writing, it helps me out. I would love to have it driving my car. I don't have a self-driving car yet, but I'll get there. You know, I'm also
看着，你知道，可能还需要10年。我将需要一辆自动驾驶汽车。我希望那能巧合。所以，所以我没有一辆完全自动化的汽车。等等，你认为在10年后，Sean，你将处于一种无法驾驶汽车的状态吗？我认为我快到了，对吧？我超过60岁了，感觉到了年龄。所以，所以绝对感觉我在过去五年里慢了很多。所以是的，你知道，我认为有巨大的潜在上升空间。我只是认为应对这一点是一个挑战。社会可能会很好地应对它。
looking at, you know, probably 10 more years. I'm going to need a self-driving car. I'm hoping that that coincide. So, so I don't have just a fully automated car. Wait, you think in 10 years time, Sean, you will be in such a state where you would not be able to drive a car? I think I'm getting close enough now, right? I'm past 60 and feeling the age. So, so definitely feeling like I have slowed down a lot in the last five years. So yeah, you know, I think there's huge potential upside. I just think there is a challenge to navigate this. Societies may navigate it well.
我怀疑它会是混乱的。希望它会是混乱的并且应对得很好，但存在巨大的风险。而且我认为我们低估了这种风险，对吧？当人们谈论，你知道，哦，人工智能的生存威胁并想到《终结者》时，我不认为那是《终结者》。我认为那是巨大的贫富差距，你知道，导致战争，对吧？没错。我认为那才是生存威胁。
I suspect it will be chaotic. Hopefully it will be chaotic and navigated well, but there is huge risk. And I think we are underestimating the risk, right? When people talk about kind of, you know, oh, the existential threat of AI and think Terminator, I don't think it's Terminator. I think it's a massive wealth disparity. and, you know, leading to war, right? Right. I think that's the existential threat.
一场内战？或者？不，推翻政府之类的，你知道。因为，你知道，如果你有大量的失业，你知道。是的。是的。我认为如果你有一个，你知道，它看起来更像，你知道，俄罗斯沙皇的倒台。这不幸的是可能导致你最终处于一个，你知道，在一个，在一个，在一个，在一个像那样的接管中，你最终也会得到一个不受欢迎的政治结构，并且在它被改革或推翻之前必须经历一段时间，而且你知道，推翻政府往往是暴力和混乱的。我认为我们倾向于认为社会正沿着线性路径进步，但从历史上看，没有证据表明社会总是会进步，对吧？帝国兴衰。
A civil war? Or? No, overthrow the government type of, you know. Because, you know, if you have a huge amount of unemployment, you know. Yeah. Yeah. I think if you have a, you know, it looks more like, you know, the fall of the SARS in Russia. which unfortunately probably leads to you end up with an you know in a in a in a in a takeover like that you you end up with with also an undesirable political structure and that has to go through a period before it gets gets you know reformed or overthrowing and and you know overthrowing governments tends to be violent and messy I think we tend to think of society is progressing along a linear path but historically there's no evidence that that society always improves, right? Empires rise and fall.
你最终会进入黑暗时代。你最终会经历巨大、巨大的动荡时期。我不认为有任何保证我们能很好地度过这个过渡期。我的希望是我们能做到。我的希望是它仍然是一个巨大的机会，也许人工智能帮助我们更好地应对了这一点。当你提到《终结者》时，
You end up with dark ages. You end up with huge, huge periods of turmoil. I don't think there's any guarantees that we navigate this transition well. My hope is we do. My hope is it remains a great opportunity and maybe the AI has helped us navigate this better. When you said Terminator,
我不是《终结者》，它会更像，我以为你会说《机器人总动员》，每个人都漂浮在他们的，你知道，悬浮椅上，啜饮着苏打水。但我猜我太天真了，认为每个人都会接受他们缺乏目的和意义，而且在通往那里的路上会更接近，人们会说，不，这太糟糕了。就像，为什么，是的，为什么要忍受这个，他们采取行动？我猜还没有关于那个的电影。我听说Andrew Garfield被选中在一部名为《Artificial》的电影中扮演Sam Altman。真的吗？所以也许这就是那部电影的结局。
I was not Terminator, It's going to be more like, I thought you were going to say Wally, where everyone's floating around in their, you know, hover chairs, sipping on soda. But that's, that's naive of me, I guess, to think that everyone's going to accept their lack of purpose and meaning, and it's going to be closer to, on the way to that, people are like, no, this sucks. Like, why, yeah, why stand for this and they take matters into their own hands? I guess there's no movie for that yet. I've heard that Andrew Garfield has been cast to play Sam Altman in a movie called Artificial. Really? So maybe that's how that movie is going to end.
我们不知道。是的。你知道，我认为《星际迷航》是这里典型的，你知道，光明的未来社会，对吧？当然，他们是《星际迷航》的粉丝。他们必须经历第三次世界大战才能到达那里。但是，你知道，他们对一个人们是有意义和富有成效的，并且被照顾得很好的社会有一个愿景，所以《星际迷航》里有全民基本收入吗，我只看到没有钱，那就像一个后货币社会，对吧？是的，它就像一个后货币社会，你有
We don't know. Yeah. You know, I think Star Trek is kind of the canonical, you know, bright future society here, right? Of course, they're Star Trek fan. They had to go through a third world war to get there. But, you know, they have a vision of a society where people are, are meaningful and productive and then taking care of right so is there ubi in uh in star trek i've only see no money that's like a post money society right yeah it's like a post money society you have
呃，呃，他们当然有，你知道，智能计算机，远没有我认为我们正在走向的那么智能。科幻小说总是低估计算机而高估其他一切，这很有趣。是的，等等，它们是什么，它们是什么，因为我见过，这是，我要失去一些书呆子信誉了，尽管我已经提到，你知道，我们正在重做我们的方式，我正在重做我的方式，Hishima第一次看到它们，星球大战。我看过最新的《星际迷航》电影，由Chris Pine和非常帅气的Zachary Quinto主演，我想是扮演Spock的那个人。
uh uh they certainly have you know intelligent computers not nearly as intelligent as i think is what we're headed for it is funny how sci-fi always underestimates the computers and overestimates everything else yeah So wait, what are they, what are they, because I've seen, this is, I'm going to lose some nerd cred here, even though I've mentioned that, you know, we're reworking our way through, I'm reworking my way through, Hishima's seeing them for the first time, Star Wars. I've seen the latest Star Trek movies, which were starring Chris Pine and the very good looking Zachary Quinto, I think, was the guy that played Spock.
总之，我想有一两三部。我看了那些。我不认为有很多关于社会基础设施的讨论。货币或财政运作。那么《星际迷航》传说的基础是什么？你知道，他们没有详细说明社会是如何结构或治理的，但这是一个世界范围的政府，一个单一的世界范围政府。它是一种非货币的、某种形式的社会主义结构。
Anyways, I think there was one or two or three of those. I saw those. I don't think there was much talk of the infrastructure about society. monetarily or fiscally operated. So what are the basics of Star Trek lore? You know, they don't go into details as far as how society is structured or governed, but it's a worldwide government, a single worldwide government. It's a non-monetary, somewhat socialist structure of some form.
他们在第三次世界大战后到达了那里。世界大战，那是一场优生学战争，你知道，社会的一个派系正在修改基因以试图基本上成为超人，并将社会结构分为统治的超人和其余的人。那最终导致了一场大战。那是Con来的地方吗？是的，那是Con来的地方。好的，好的。
They ended up there after the third world. World War, which was a eugenics war, you know, a faction of society was modifying genes to try to basically become superhuman and divide the structure of society between the superhumans that ruled and the rest of the people. And that ended up in a big war. And was that where Con came from? Yeah, that's where Con came from. Okay, okay.
那是在电影里。我记得那个。你知道，而且在许多电影中，他们有，你知道，他们城市的镜头，旧金山在电影中经常出现，就像，哦，这些美丽的城市，每个人都穿着得体，干净，四处走动，他们有可爱的公寓，一切都是自动化的，但他们仍然每天去工作，他们都有工作，他们都有任务要做，所以你知道，这是一个非常，呃，呃，理想主义的社会观，所以以那个为目标，减去第三次世界大战，是的，如果我们能，如果我们能在没有第三次世界大战的情况下到达那里，那会很好，如果我们能停止威胁，你知道，接管格陵兰岛，那会很好，我没想到我们会说这些句子，呃，几年前，考虑到加拿大在，考虑到Connor在加拿大，也许我们可以从不威胁对加拿大做事情开始。
That was in the movie. I remember that. you know and and in many of the movies they have you know shots of their cities and san francisco is you know commonly comes up in the movies and it's like oh these beautiful cities with everybody nicely dressed and clean and walking around and they have lovely apartments and everything's automated but they still go to work every day and they all have jobs and they all have tasks to do so you know it's a it's a very uh uh idealistic view of society be so aim for that minus the the third world war yeah if we can if we can get there without the third world war that would be nice if we could stop threatening you know taking over greenland that would be nice sentences i wouldn't have thought we would say uh some number of years ago given canada's in in giving connor's in canada maybe we can start with threat not threatening to do things to Canada.
你们那里的第51个州怎么样？还可以。我们选出了一位非常，非常，你知道，在被提名之前一直不为人知，然后每个人都爱上了他，总理。他很棒。我的意思是，我一直是Trudeau的粉丝。我可能失去了一些听众，但我认为他是一个很棒的公关人员，总是做正确的事，在Tim Hortons握手。他是一个很棒的，你知道。那是加拿大的事情吗，握手？你不亲吻婴儿。你只是去Tim Horton。
How is things in our 51st state up there? It's all right. We elected a very, very, you know, unknown right until he was nominated and then everyone fell in love with him, Prime Minister. He's great. I mean, I was always a fan of Trudeau. I might have lost a couple listeners there, but I thought he was a great PR guy, always did the right thing, shakes the hands and Tim Hortons. He was a great, you know. Is that the Canadian thing, it shakes the hands? You don't kiss the babies. You just go to the Tim Horton.
我认为人们很多时候误解了什么是政治，其中很多只是公关。而且我认为，在很大程度上，他在公关方面很棒。他的垮台只是因为他是现任者，你知道，人们在全球范围内都很不满。所以是时候结束了。但他总是做这些事情，他会去Tim Hortons和某人握手。我想，那真是太棒了。
I think people misunderstand what politics is a lot of the time, and a lot of it is just PR. And I think, for the most part, he was great at PR. And his downfall was just that he was the incumbent, you know, and people were upset globally. And so it was his time to end. But he always did these things where he would go to Tim Hortons and shake hands with someone. I was like, that's just brilliant.
这真是太棒了。你知道，就像每个人都知道我们是因为Tim Hortons，没有人讨厌Tim Hortons，就像我不是他们甜甜圈的超级粉丝，但没有人讨厌它，这是一个买便宜咖啡和甜甜圈的好地方，而且，总之，我们，我们，我们选出了新人，他一直很棒，只是看着他以及他如何与你们的领导人打交道，这很神奇，这很神奇，他的第一次互动，他出来，他是第一个出来开始谈论特朗普正在做伟大事情的国家领导人，你知道，你实际上没有给出任何具体细节。他只是说，我认为你，你做了一些非常大胆的事情，你做了一些大胆的事情，
It's just brilliant. you know like everybody knows us for tim hortons nobody hates tim hortons like i'm not a huge fan of their donuts but nobody hates it it's a good place for a cheap cup of coffee and a donut and uh anyways we we uh we elected the new guy and he's been great just watching him and how he deals with your leader is amazing it's amazing his first interaction he comes out he was the first he was the first nation state leader to come out and start talking about how trump was doing great things you know You didn't actually give any specifics. He just said, I think you're, you've made some really bold, you've done some bold things,
你可以看到特朗普对此很高兴。然后看看这个，就在过去一周，你让所有欧洲国家的领导人都复制了我们的人所做的，并说了一堆，哦，你很棒，你很棒。不过，我们的播客会被关掉，你知道。我猜《南方公园》还在播出。所以只要《南方公园》还在，我们可能就是安全的。但你不必担心，因为你不是那个会被扔进古拉格的人，你是，他们必须，他们必须，你知道，来找你，对吧，呃
and you could see Trump being happy about it. And then look at this, just in the last week, you've got all the leaders of the European countries copying basically what our guy did and saying a bunch of, oh, you're great, you're great. We're going to get our podcast shut down, though, you know. I guess South Park is, they're still being aired. So as long as South Park is up, we're probably safe. But you don't have to worry because you're not the one who's going to get thrown in the gulock you're you're up and they'd have to they'd have to you know come for you right uh
我的意思是，我的意思是，我们不应该开始预测你的总统会做什么和不会做什么，因为，呃，他已经做了很多我这辈子从未想过会从一个，你知道，美国在任的……这是真的，这是真的，是的，是的，总之，我觉得我们有点脱轨了，但这有点，呃，有点希望，以《星际迷航》为目标，减去，减去世界大战，希望绝对不是《终结者》，或者当你提到贫富差距时，我想到的另一部剧是《碳变》，因为那是贫富差距达到100%或200%，富人住在天空之上，他们基本上是不朽的，因为他们可以进出他们的意识，他们把身体视为，你知道，就像可替换的东西，所以富人
i mean i mean we shouldn't start making predictions about what what your president will and will not do because uh he's already done a bunch of stuff that i never thought i'd see in my lifetime from a you know a u.s sitting u. that is true that is true yeah yeah anyways i feel like we've kind of flown off the rail here but that was uh somewhat hopeful aim for aim for star track minus the minus the World War and hopefully definitely not Terminator or the other show that comes to mind is Project Carbon when you mention the wealth disparity is because that's kind of the wealth disparity gone to 100% or 200% and the rich people live above the sky and they're basically immortal because they can pop in and out their consciousness and they treat bodies as you know just like replaceable things and so the wealthy
我的意思是，我们不应该开始预测你们的总统会做什么或不会做什么，因为他已经做了一堆我这辈子从未想过会从一位美国在任总统身上看到的事情。确实如此，确实如此。是的，是的。总之，我觉得我们有点跑题了，但那是一个充满希望的目标，目标是《星际迷航》，减去世界大战，当然绝对不是《终结者》。当你提到贫富差距时，我想到的另一个节目是《碳变》，因为那基本上是贫富差距达到了100%或200%的情况，富人住在云端之上，他们基本上是不朽的，因为他们可以随意进出自己的意识，把身体仅仅当作可替换的物品，所以富人
people, they always have spare bodies and their consciousness backed up, whereas poor folks have none of that and death is real for them. Anyways, let's not do that. Let's not do that. Fun show to watch. Probably a terrible reality to live in. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion
人们总是拥有备用身体，意识也都有备份，而穷人则完全没有这些，对他们来说死亡是真实的。总之，我们还是别那样做了。别那样做。这节目看起来很有趣，但生活在那种现实中恐怕会很糟糕。请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用中，还是在ADSP thepodcast.com网站上，都可以找到我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个讨论帖的链接，
where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. we hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. That's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有愉快的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。那不是标语。我们的标语是带有信息碎片的混乱。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。